she was someone who was loved by
everyone who worked with and liked by
everyone who worked with and admired
an emotional alec baldwin visibly shaken
during an interview with abc news's
george stephanopoulos
their conversation will air in full on
thursday december 2nd but on wednesday
the network released a clip of what's to
come you haven't said much in public
since that tragic accident why speak out
now i think the big question
and the one you must have asked yourself
a thousand times
how could this have happened it's the
actor's first sit down since the october
tragedy on the set of rust when baldwin
reportedly fired a prop gun that
accidentally killed cinematographer
helena hutchins and wounded director
joel souza an investigation into the
shooting is ongoing during the interview
baldwin denies claims that he pulled the
trigger that fired the fatal shot it
wasn't in the script for the trigger to
be pulled well the trigger wasn't pulled
i didn't pull the trigger so you never
pulled the trigger no no no no i would
never point a gun at anyone and pull a
trigger at them never what did you think
happened the actor raises questions
about how the live bullet got on the set
in the first place how did a real bullet
get on that set i have no idea someone
put a live bullet in a gun a bullet that
wasn't even supposed to be on the
property he also reflects on what he
could have done differently to prevent
the accident that ended in tragedy you
said you're not a victim but is this the
worst thing that's ever happened to you
yes
yep
yeah
because i
i think back
and i think of what could i have done
in the meantime e.t has obtained new
documents that shed light on what
happened on set that day an affidavit
claims the film's armorer hannah
gutierrez reid told investigators that
the weapon was checked on set but that
she quote didn't really check it too
much
gutierrez reid also may have put blame
on baldwin the document claiming that
the armorer said quote they weren't even
supposed to be pulling the hammer back
but back to baldwin's interview on
wednesday's good morning america
stephanopoulos who co-anchors the show
opened up about what it was like having
such an emotional conversation with the
actor i've done thousands of interviews
in the last 20 years at abc this was the
most
intense i've ever experienced he was
also very candid he was very forthcoming
he answered every question he talked
about helena hutchins talked about
meeting with her family as well went
through in detail
what happened on the set that day and i
have to tell you i was surprised
[Music]